un dimanche au capital pour l'avenir
politique d'haïti chez le conseil
supérieur du pouvoir judiciaire a
reconnu la fin du mandat du président je
venais la moise contestée est accusé de
vouloir le prolonger illégalement il
maintient qu'il lui reste un nom ou
pouvoir l'institution s'est déclaré
vivement préoccupé par les graves
menaces résultant d'une absence d'accord
politique l'on redoute des violences sur
l'île réaction de jacques bessy
politologue et membre du laboratoire
caribéen de sciences sociales ce plan
institutionnel vient se greffer sur un
ensemble de frustration de déception
parce que on considère que ce qu'ils
donnent la république est versé dans
l'autocratie
depuis un an il dit il gouverne seul il
n'y a pas de parlement il décide seul
sans rendre compte à personne
exemple il a nommé le directeur de la
police nationale
seul il a nommé aussi les principaux
dirigeants de la bo nationale de la
république d'haïti de la banque
nationale de crédit les ambassadeurs
autrement dit c'est glee d'oran qui y
exercent seuls sans contre-pouvoir la
totalité du bois nadia lançant un pays
qui est traditionnellement dictatorial
alors qu'il y a un effort qui est
engagée 1986 vers la démocratie
donc cet exercice autocratique
contribuer à jeter le trouble a créé
l'inquiétude
l'étude qui va donc caussieu facteurs
ablement pour l'investissement